hello the world Wow beer chat it's
really cool where is the whiskey
there's no whiskey Wow thank you okay
any man
princess I'll be on my way now I was
just leaving absolutely but no no thank
you I'm crouched over and I'm clenching
real hard right now I had really bad
Mexican that's okay that's okay because
I will just clean it myself I really
appreciate the other cab um no you can't
do that either
okay well that's illegal
all right so just back up it's done
illegal it's it's to me all right okay
you're freaking me out
nothing will go up my BOB
you're way too big at least let me
change my avatar for this at least I
might make your cake look bigger if I go
up your bum okay that's just disturbing
okay all right what if I
all right how about this huh how about
this Oh God how are you going hello can
I get a hug hello oh thank you that was
great
hello everybody it's your boy wreck-it
Ralph
drink it Ralph huh
thanks goddamn right I'm little round
things I reckon to again I wreck your
mamma's [ __ ] how about the headshot
doing his side daddy stay away from me
alright alright I'm Ricky brown that's
fine I don't wreck someone will wreck
someone else's business cake you're
scaring Peter just stick your skin I am
scared
rivets at least get I don't know that's
work but I made it up that's so scared I
am
that is my drink good old record
breaking things
yes that is a microaggression
oh you want to go prepare guys is way
harder he is so hot you're like
spaghetti if I sweep why would you do
that to a lady why don't you do that to
the lady to a lady and so sorry milady
okay treat treat me treat me with some
respect okay you you male privileged guy
white wreck-it Ralph don't you know my
struggle did you not watch my movie I'm
sorry someone had to say it oh wow
doesn't this make you just feel like
dancing
hell yeah no that's right I get it now I
just kind of showed them my feet beer
[Music]
it's cold you're breaking my immersion
i'm so triggered
oh my god it's Jar Jar Binks everybody
what an honor to meet you it's Amis oh
my god it's the real one the Italian one
oh you sound like jacksepticeye that's
right I am jacksepticeye how you found
me you win a hug come here mr. Jack
brofist
that's not what jacksepticeye does all
right of course
[Music]
how you doing they're not fat
look I can see in the mirror I can tell
I'm not fat I'm not fat okay
I'm not your beasts feels great
excuse me I'm shaking it Hey come on get
up this magic please do love you get up
I don't need it okay
oh my god yep look at all the anime
girls are you doing hey you doing that's
very nice
hello whole anime girls you wanna come
with me oh thank you you and it you
wanna go with Saliva's alright you want
to go with me hello hello
wanna be my girlfriend so does anyone
want to be my girlfriend please please
be my girlfriend I'll do anything please
and sorry
assuming myself I will be your gum I'll
do anything
no one loves me
[Music]
please be my girlfriend someone oh hell
yeah oh hell yeah that's what
[Music]